there's a guy alive that isn't to
telomeres telomeres yeah that's your
longevity Chaney
sure and he said that people that are
like phone the Lord Horrocks people that
you know conduct pansies silly guys and
[ __ ] silly musicians right Oh silly
[ __ ] silly silly comedians right people
that are able to let let a childish side
of them out those little Hollywood Hills
stay longer mmm old people they grow
shorter and he's close to finding that
out
so I love I love today I love what's
going on I'm gonna look into this yeah
please do we'll talk afterwards I'll
give you some names new years and [ __ ]
too
to look up but so so Mme you know I'm
looking at it and one of the girls that
works for me said well that's the same
thing as what you're into right now
Mme for me I'm at mm-hmm only use it
something no no it's something I got
into in the last year with my lawyer
Dean olap old and it's called I'm sick
and [ __ ] tired of getting beat and
ripped off for the songs I wrote yeah in
the 70s and where's the money where's
the money so I get a joke right it's not
even a joke and now that there's a
format that's digital it's even less of
a joke you want to [ __ ] go break into
these buildings to take a gun and shoot
people because they're a pain you mean
things like Spotify and they're not
right there they're taking the money for
plays of your song they're giving you
whatever first of all publishers you
know what it's all about
100 years ago 50 years ago 20 years ago
publishers take the money we make on
Toys in the Attic millions right they
keep that money for a year
they put it in the bank they keep the
interest right then they pay after they
keep the interest of course so that's
that's one of those members before is in
the so many dirty things like to tell
you how about us how about finding out
managers by the first three rows of your
shows and and get the money from the
[ __ ] promoter in their pocket brought
to them in a paper bag you want to
[ __ ] go there that what it does is
that what happened that's the kind of
[ __ ] that no it's kind of [ __ ] that
happens in a business so they buy the
first three rows and that is how simple
they go up to the guy this is the guy's
assuming that the show right if you have
a 90/10 deal [ __ ] great the manager
goes and goes to the first three rows
see you later or you don't get Aerosmith
Wow or you don't get Bob Dylan
well you don't get Jimmy Buffett and
they're just depending upon those people
did not tell you yeah I mean who's gonna
tell you you only fight cuz here's what
happens you only find that [ __ ] out
afterwards if you're going out with a
girl that says I'm the one that brought
the money back to him oh is that how you
found that I said how I found out
somebody found out that way that's the
story I heard oh let's keep it like that
and it's a story
this woman's willing to talk about oh
but but the deal here's a deal you know
you know I'd love to get angry as [ __ ]
about stuff I love that I'm Italian you
kidding you know what's so funny I got
sober right now what you have an anger
management problem Stephen once you got
sober I [ __ ] you what you know what I
mean here's the you know you think when
you get sober you're off the drugs your
isms or was ins right [ __ ]
oh you're all the reason you drank for
all the reasons that you drank they come
out even more right and then you have to
manage or learn but you gotta learn her
right that's a good thing
well exercise right well you know he's
gonna look research PE malady you know
your cocoa dependency no more just [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] stuff spiritual stuff how
do I rise above your your your
abnormalities it's not so good to smack
your wife when you get angry
definitely not no you gotta learn how to
what - how to manage that anger